Hi, there, my name is Bradley Knapp,
and I'm with IBM Cloud.
And the question that I want to
answer for you guys today is
what is a LAMP Stack?
So we've gotten some questions and
comments in the past.
We've had people approach us and
they say, Hey, I hear this
referenced all the time.
I have absolutely no idea what a
LAMP stack is.
This is not something I'm familiar
with. And so LAMP
is an acronym.
It stands for Linux, Apache,
MySQL, and PHP,
and it is the stack
of software that,
at its most fundamental, makes
the internet run.
And I know that seems kind
of bizarre and kind of an outlandish
claim, but I can assure you that the
internet exists in the form
that we use it today in the form
that we consume it today because
of the LAMP Stack.
And so first, I want to go through
like, what are those components?
And then we're going to talk about
how they work.
So if we think about running a
website right in order
to run a website, you have to have
some sort of a server now.
That server.
Could be a physical server.
It could be a virtual server.
It could be in a data
center. It could be running in
cloud. It could be in a Colo
facility. It could be just
a laptop that's plugged into your
room. But you have to have some
sort of a computer hardware
to run that website.
You have to have something that is
turned on and has electricity
network access.
And then on top of
that hardware, you have the floor
LAMP components, right?
The first one that we're going to
talk about here.
Is our Linux?
Linux is the free, open source
software that is an operating
system.
It's community supported, it's
community developed, and
Linux is that operating system that
forms most of the internet.
It is the underlying operating
system of the internet writ
large, and Linux
comes in lots of different flavors,
right? You've got pure
Linux, if you will.
So the pure Linux kernel, you
have Ubuntu from Canonical, you
have Red Hat, you have SUSE,
you have CentOS, you have Mint.
All different flavors, but all using
the same underlying kernel or close
enough that it really doesn't
matter. But again, it's free.
It's freely distributed.
Anybody can go download it,
compile it, install it and get it
running.
That's the URL.
All right. Our next piece in our
lamp stack is our aye
aye is Apache.
Apache, again, free, open
source software from the Apache
Foundation.
Apache is the web
server layer, so Apache software
that you install on your Linux
operating system onto the server
and the point of Apache is to be
able to understand
all of those incoming network
requests.
What do they mean and what
do I send back when I'm done?
So Apache is the actual web server
itself if you want to think about
the web server being its own
standalone software.
And then the next piece,
that's our M,
L M and
are M is for MySQL.
MySQL is a free, open
source, SQL Structured Query
Language Database.
Again, free, open source
community developed, community
supported so anybody can go
down, install it or download
it, compile it, install it and run
it. And the idea behind
MySQL is it is
the database layer for your
LAMP stack. It's the database for
your website. Well, what is the
database?
A database has tables in it.
Inside the tables.
We store data.
And so if you think about going to a
website where you're going to log
in, right, that website
prompts you for credentials.
What's your username and your
password?
Before you could log into
it, you had to register for it.
You had to give it your name, your
address, your telephone number, your
email address, so on and so forth.
All of that data that you input
goes into this database.
And so when you log in, it's going
to go and it's going to check
against the database to say, Hey,
does this user name match?
Does this password match?
So that's the database.
That's where all of the data that
is dynamic is housed.
And then our fourth, are P,
and this goes down here at the
bottom.
We've got all of our components.
How do we write the site?
Well, we need a language.
And that's what PHP is
for. PHP Is the most
commonly used language in
running websites, building websites.
PHP is again, it is free,
it is community written.
It is community supported.
Anybody can download it.
Anybody can compile it.
And anybody can install.
It is far and away
the most common language used
for scripting or writing
websites.
And so that's a description.
These are the components of the LAMP
stack. Let's talk about how do they
work?
And so let's imagine
a guy.
This guy is smiling,
we'll give him a little smile.
He's got a laptop, right, so his
laptop?
He wants to get on to it, and he
wants to go to your website, and so
he's going to send a request
down here to
your server that's running.
Way up.
And he's going to say, Hey, please
send me your front page.
And so that request that's
going to come in.
Let me let's do our
L., A., M.
P. here.
So that request that's going to come
in the request is going to be,
Hey, please send this to me.
So it's going to come in.
It's going to hit the Apache
and say, Hey, this guy wants the
website.
Apache is going to say, All right,
well, we need to send it out.
So let me run the code
to the VP to send
HTML back so that it knows what to
display.
Let me access that m the MySQL
database to say, Hey, what data
are we going to send back?
Is there anything in the database
we're going to send or is it all
static or hard coded?
And it's going to talk to the URL to
the Linux and say, Hey, operating
system, this incoming request.
It's good to go, and we're going to
send this data back to
him. We're going to send back the
code, we're going to send back the
data and we're going to send
it back in this web compliant
standard method.
And so it is then going to transmit
those via packets back
to our guy with our laptop, and he's
going to be able to view the
website.
Everything that he clicks on
is going to generate a new series
of communications back and forth
between his laptop and the server
running the lamp stack to serve
up all of the images to serve up the
text, to serve up the prompts.
Anything that moves.
Anything that's intelligent,
the underlying components
are exactly the same.
And so you'll see other videos on
this channel that talk about other
kinds of web servers.
LAMP is far and away.
The longest serving it is the most
popular. It's the one that's been
around the longest, and
it really doesn't matter what web
framework you're going to use.
At the end of the day, the
underlying architecture
depends on the exact same things
that we scripted out 15 years ago
when the LAMP Stack was originally
developed.
And so hopefully that's been good
information for you.
As always, if you have any
questions, please feel free to put
them into the comments.
I do actually try and come in and
answer them somebody else from IBM
be able to answer them if you want
to get really in-depth.
Please reach out to your IBM
team and we'll see what we can do to
help you out.
Thank you so much for stopping by
the channel today.
If you have any questions or
comments, please feel free to share
them with us below.
If you enjoyed this video and you
would like to see more like it in
the future, please do like the video
and subscribe to us so that will
know to keep creating for you.